네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다 어
저희가 이번에 빌딩 투자 스터디
31기를 시작을 합니다 저희 스터디는
2016년도에 처음 시작을 해 가지고
무려 8년 동안 어 이어온 그런
스터디 강입니다 8년 동안 하면서
그동안 쌓아온 그런 데이터라는
노하우를 가지고 강의 준비를 수정
보안을 좀 많이 했고요 빌딩 투자할
때 반드시 좀 도움이 될 만한 어
내용들 위주로 좀 준비를 했습니다네
그래서 일정은 4월 22일 날 시작을
해 가지고 4월 27일 5월 10
1일 5월 18일 5월 25일 그래서
매주 토요일 날 진행을 할 예정입니다
2시부터는 예정이고 그리고 2주차
때부터는 답사 그니까 현장 답사를 할
예정입니다 그래서 강의 시작하기 전에
조원들이랑 같이 해서 어 답사를 좀
진행할 예정이고요 스터디 내용은 지금
현재 빌딩 시장 사항이나 앞으로 빌딩
투자를 어떻게 해야 되는지 진짜
기본적인 건폐율 용적률이 등기 사항
전문 주면서 보는 방법이라든지 뭐
건축물 대장 보는 방법이라든지 아예
기본적인 내용부터 조금 이제 심화되는
내용까지 다룰 예정이고요 그리고 성공
사례도 좀 많이 말씀드리겠지만 실패
사례도 좀 많이 말씀드립니다 유튜브에
사실 실패 사례를 말씀드릴 순
없거든요 근데 스터디 강의 같은
경우에는 실패 사례를 좀 많이
말씀드립니다 생각보다 빌딩 투자 실패
사례가 좀 많이 있습니다 공개가 안
되는 경우가 많은데 그런 실패
사례들도 좀 많이 다룰 예정이고 빌딩
세무와 관련돼서는 회계사 님이 와서
강의를 해 주실 거고 그다음에 이제
건축사님 님이 건물 설계라는 공사에
대해서 어 강의를 해 주실 겁니다
그리고 저희 건설사 대표님까지 오셔
가지고 시공할 때 뭐 이렇게 주의해야
될 점이라든지 이런 전체적으로 좀
설명을 해 주실 예정이고 정말 빌딩
투자할 때 반드시 필요한 전문가들을
다 준비를 했습니다 저희 스터디의
가장 큰 이유가 전 성공 사례를 좀
많이 만들고 싶거든요 그래서 뭐
저희한테 진짜 굳이 안 맡기시고 빌딩
투자할 때 편하게 물어볼 전문가가
옆에 있는게 되게 중요하거든요 뭐
은행이라는 아니면은 뭐 빌딩
세금이라는 아니면은 건축사 님이라는
아니면 공사하려고 하는데 건설사
대표님이라 그지 이런 분들을 사실
만나기가 되게 어렵잖아요 저희
스터디를 신청을 하시면이 분들과
연결이 될 수 있습니다 그래서이
강의를 들으시면 전문가분들과 좀
연결이 되고 그리고 빌딩 투자할 때
알아야 될 항목들을 31기 동안
하면서 좀 축적해서 준비를 했기
때문에 빌딩 투자하는데이 강의가
반드시 도움이 될 거라고 저는 확신을
합니다 그 지금 사실 시장 사항이
좋지 않다가 최근에 이제 금리가
내린다는 이야기들이 많잖아요 그러면서
빌딩 거래량이 올해부터 조금 살아나기
시작했고 하반기에는 더 늘어날 것으로
예상이 되거든요 지금 같은 시기에
기회를 잡으실 어 빌딩을 투자하실
분들은 저희 스터디 신청해 주시면
좋을 것 같습니다 4월 20일 날
인사드리도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다
n